it's all
tough it's all tough life is hard
just keep going
and never stop and get that money and
buy properties yeah life's a garden dig
it oh [__] i hate that me too
me too don't like that that's right
[Music]
[Laughter]
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying
[Music]
do you think fans care if about anyone's
schedule like hour to hour maybe
i wonder oh like any fans any
celebrities celebrity no i mean mark
wahlberg maybe breaks about 2 30 if it's
very weird how long then are we going to
believe that all that you know i mean i
you know he definitely has woken up at 2
30 to work out probably one when he's
like in the middle of shooting or he's
jet lagged or some [__] when he has to
not every day no way does somebody wake
up at 2 30 every day
that's horse [__] you got to go to sleep
at [__] 6 30. that's what he says
he's like yeah i'll do my work dumb in
bed by six months
also like you're just kind of like
proving how you're like kind of exposing
to the world how annoying you are if you
do that like how annoying is that dude i
gotta so i will have six hours to ev
like if i'm his wife i have six hours
with you if you're his kids yeah yeah i
got to see you guys between 1 and 2 30.
yeah yeah yeah daddy's daddy is waking
up [__] four hours before you wake up
oh he's oh he this is him here posting
every day yeah no no that's chicago oh
different animal different animal jocko
that's his whole life though this is
this guy he's not sad he's not out there
playing a [__] so he wakes up at 4 30
bro yeah man what does jonko go to bed
that's a good question i want to know
when i would like to see a watch with
what time he's going to jump into this
sheet 3 47 he woke up he'll go to bed
he'll try to go to bed between 10 and 11
but
sometimes he doesn't get that and then
when he's tired during the day he allows
him to himself to take five-minute naps
or he'll lay on the couch and he'll
elevate his feet yeah that's what i
heard that does probably nothing huh
five minutes you're just asleep and your
feet fall asleep too but jocko makes
sense i mean the guy has been through
war he's done several tours he's killed
people with his bare hands that all
makes sense
that's crazy mark wahlberg no dude
you're in transformer savage he just
played a priest yeah like it's all good
dude he funded his own you don't have to
do that that one yeah he funded it
because no one really wanted to do it
dude i don't know why actors don't do
that more
like you know people are always like
like a lot of actors will be complaining
i don't get the parts i don't this and
that you're [__] you made so much
money off of some [__] why don't you
[__] fund some [__] that's a lot of
money here i understand but it doesn't
have to though these people well mark
wahlberg get what you got like 500
million dollars at least yeah he could
make a 10 million dollar movie yeah i
mean he's he get paid on the back end
but nobody's going to see that [__]
stew movie right that's what's called
father stew or whatever went straight
nobody's going to [__] see it dude
nobody sees anything anyway unless he's
transformers would you uh
i was talking to mark about this before
he came in would you take your son to
see the new
um
does light year yeah i think so why it's
just it's not doing well because the
narrative before it came out right
there's a gay character that it's a
female character i kissed another female
character
but when they first announced that
there's a gay character in my head i'm
like oh buzz lightyear's gonna like suck
off woody or something that might be a
lot versus yeah it might not be rated g
but yeah i'm like i'm not taking my son
to that buzz is sucking off woody sure
well if anyone's sucking off anyone
don't bring any sun to anything yeah you
never know if it's cartoons or whatever
but yeah but um if it's a girl kiss
another girl i guess i i don't care you
know i don't give a [__] oh sorry like i
go but i would buy something and
even me like i i
didn't take them
oh wow really yeah i'm super pro-gay
friends i don't care interesting but i
might like bust out the door to go see
it apparently a lot of america's not
either because you can't they can't show
this movie overseas china was like oh
we're out really russia went check
please yeah oh dude i can't wait to see
the but like they're all pretending that
they're for this [__] and they're
they're like what is it uh pixar or i
don't know this is disney yeah dude i
just can't wait till they backtrack and
they're just like oh
you know well it's not it's always about
money dude like they try to act like
they care they don't care
nobody cares who kisses anybody they
only [__] give a [__] is about the
money dude and if nobody's seeing buzz
lightyear people already [__] mad at
chris pratt because he's [__]
religious or whatever you know religious
and he's whatever the [__] it is yeah
he's religious but then he's also i
think a little bit far right he hunts
yeah i don't know if he's far right i
just said that i spread the rumors i
love love chris pratt dude yeah he's
cool yeah he's a nice guy i don't you
know i don't give a [__] but that's also
like with the rock remember with rogan
he was like i can't wait to come on the
show and drink some tequila with you and
then people like have you seen rogue's
recent opinions on whatever vaccinations
yeah and then he was like oh wasn't
aware bottom line yeah i think it was
the yeah yeah but i bet behind closed
doors he's he's a bro oh dude i would
bet my last dollar who has a billion
dollars that's a democrat who has a
billion dollars that's a democrat pelosi
yeah yeah because she's made a career
being a democrat correct but if you're
not
making a career out of being a
politician you got a billion dollars oh
you're republican as [__] yeah daddy
because you like those tax breaks yeah
dude it's
always all about money
but but think about it if you're like
it's a double-edged sword if you're the
rock or you're john cena or you're
johnny depp you can't
come out and give any of you i know i
know i know because it's going to [__]
with your movies i know i know that's
why john cena so they had a female kiss
a female and and people are it's not
bombing the movie's not bombing is it
for a pixar movie it's fine really
because of that yeah i heard i heard she
takes suit off and grabs her tits and
ugh okay well that may not be true that
maybe hearsay but wow
go up go up box office behind the pixar
movies family problem wow interesting
dude
but i think i don't think america is
anti-gay they're not they know i think
they're like oh i just don't want my
whatever six five-year-old dealing with
this what they don't just make a good
fun movie parents kids are asking you so
many [__] questions you don't want to
have to have to answer more [__]
questions they already got the questions
how do you go to outer space you're busy
for like [__] six months you don't
know how they go to outer space so
you're trying to tell your kid and
they're like well why did a girl kiss a
girl and you got to explain that too
well some people are homosexual and then
they say they don't even say what's
homosexual they say what do you what
does the word sum mean there's so many
[__] there's so many things that they
have to learn they don't want to have to
learn this too and your kids too right
yeah my six-year-old i mean probably a
year ago i picked up school and he's
like hey dad um who's jesus who does who
decides to go to heaven and i'm like oh
my god this is heavy his buddy's jewish
dad why aren't we jewish what is jewish
you know it's being jewish yeah like bro
i i gotta let me google this i don't
even know yeah yeah you got google yeah
son you got google and then go like this
and then walk away
but then he also uh the other day he
started crying i picked you we're
driving home from juicing he's balling
like what's wrong with you dude he's
gonna die someday no he goes i don't
want you to die yeah no way do you have
like a weird dream or something like
what's going on here you say no he's
like we have so much fun you're such a
good dad
right right real quick though why are
you crying like this yeah and i but i
guess i talked to uh his uh pediatrician
who you know she's not a therapist yeah
yeah a lot of kids it's common yeah you
should tell them though like that daddy
has 10 years left
i know i don't know see you're being
generous i told him four yeah i said
don't cry you force solid yeah yeah you
know you know i did as i'm driving the
bronc with the top down i took off my
shirt and started flex for my go [__] do
you think i'm dying really are you know
much stronger than the other dad that's
cute yeah that's cute that's cute he
still cried though yeah yeah well yeah
cause now he's gonna be made fun of that
he [__] had the dad that was flexing
in his bronco with the top down with the
shirt off but that's still cool i think
he'll grow up that gets cool yeah
hopefully dude wow that's a trip about
that light year thing
is it though like i could have called it
well no no it's just a trip that i think
that most people actually just they
don't want to smell an agenda i think
that like as an adult when you're going
to a movie you're like all right dude
really like this is going to be [__]
like i got i this is an agenda i know
you don't it's it's not authentic like
they don't care they care about the
money we all know it's about business
yes so when they're like yeah but we're
for this it's like dude gay people know
it's some gay people are like gay
representation but they know most of
them know it's like they're doing this
[__] because they think it [__]
affects the bottom line yeah and that's
it that's not authentic what's weird
yeah it's not authentic is the key thing
yeah
i literally don't give a [__] but i
think you know i do think
like a good majority of people are gay
are born gay they they can't do this
who'd decide that rough gig dude yeah so
i think it's dope same with like uh
black panther like if you're a young
black kid like
dope yeah
yeah so with this it's like if you're a
gay kid like even though it's not buzz
lightyear
i don't know the character's name so
it's not like woody's right right that'd
be dope if you were gay like woody's
your guy and if you were gay and also
your name was woody that's so gay but
yeah sick yeah
okay andy gets the doll and crosses his
name out because he's gay who andy the
owner of oh yeah come on dude far right
andy come on dude all right you don't
how do you not watch these movies i saw
it but like i don't remember bro here's
the thing even kids don't [__] with uh
toy story because it's so long
there's not a lot of action so sad my we
saw bad guys we saw that with the shark
[__] you saw it you're watching it
see it it just came out in the theaters
and we bought it on demand yeah he
watches every night me too my son goes
unto watch the bad guy yeah and it's so
good and you know uh uh [__] the
comics in it yeah yeah yeah
mark mary yeah yeah i thought it was
danny devito for [__] half the whole
dude i thought dak shepard was the wolf
oh yeah it does sound like i know it's
that other guy that i always forget his
name yeah me too [__] i always forget
that guy's name me too great even he
said i'd be like oh that's cool
mike or sean or bad guys is [__] good
though it's good yeah it's cool it's
fine it's bad it's not a good movie
anyway
it's not good
it makes no sense if you look at it as
an adult it makes yourself so if you
want to cry if you want to watch um
[__]
it's a it's a it's a disney movie oh
it's sad
yeah no that sounds sad it's an older
one right no it came out like oh really
two years ago okay watch onward with uh
chris pratt's in it he's the best he is
cool dude it's so good i don't like why
do you gotta make these movies like
these kids movies that cry i just i
don't i can't ever make me sad when
you're [__] with the kids movies just
make the [__]
bunny jump around and he's like oh found
some coins i don't want him to be like
my mom you know what i mean yeah she
died in a [__] avalanche that's i
can't yeah or the mom has like a heroin
addiction yeah well that actually that
would be a very cool independent movie
yeah
uh little mermaid sorry where are they
now all right dude also where's little
mermaid's mom
what do you think about that no i really
thought about that
what do you mean did you actually
immaculate conception but with the dad
think about it came out of his dick he
jerked off and she came out mermaids i
don't know
says she was run over by a big pirate
ship
has the yeah so maybe the same for oh
dude the male seahorse has the baby
which only means that the male sea horse
is the female sea horse so the female
seahorse has the baby yes and they don't
oh so maybe science mixed up who the
[__] male seahorse was is really what
sam's titus
they don't have [__] [__] or [__]
anyway dude they got a [__] whole
they're just a big green slappy fin no
no ariel had a a tank on her dude she
had a wagon she didn't have a [__]
though no she had a she had that
whacking out the back daddy yeah i find
it titties but she didn't have an ass
crack they do say a lot of disney
villains are
uh dressed in drag like oh they mean
like johnny depp and [__] alice in
wonderland use drag ursula uh jafar
ooh jafar yeah jafar did have eyeliner
on the entire movie
he did
[Music]
um all right cool the calf slicer baby
that's one of the moves they use in ufc
you know about that yeah dude how about
that hard scarf daddy that peruvian
necktie and what about that freaking
baby beater uh i don't know that one but
listen ufc 276 is here this saturday you
can watch it you can watch actually the
fight campaign in 10 p.m pacific live on
thick boy beautiful crew daddy it's this
saturday at draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of ufc
minimum age and eligibility restriction
supply he's showing us for details nick
davis is not allowed to bet all right
let's see what's up with [__] uh
johnny bravo over here i hate to go
heavy issues back-to-back oh jesus who i
like heavy he's got a debate let's get
real
kingston boys gotta keen it or stand it
for you
backing into parking spaces
just got here to the gym backed right
into an open parking spot
never felt like more of a [__] in my
entire life when i could have just gone
in really normally took a little bit uh
took too long actually that's why i feel
like a gigantic he doesn't know how to
do it appreciate the time guys thanks
bye it's way easier to back in dude it
depends what car you have no it's not a
guy who drives a ferrari i i have bigger
cars too i backing in is way easier dude
and you're just well because there's one
car what do you drive a [__] tank
me yeah
i would like a tank well what's he drive
you know what i'm saying like oh i don't
like just look at the interior of the
roof it's about assuming he doesn't have
a backup camera it's an outback talk
about a different animal dude nah i
always back in when i can back in i back
in i like to back it up it's it's easier
bro oh you're fine to me it's easier to
go it feels better now it does feel
better but driving in plus you got to
worry am i it feels like
i don't know it feels like you worry
less when you're back here bro nothing
makes you still got a low car dude
nothing makes me feel more manly when i
parallel park if it's like a tight spot
and i don't know i just have a gift to
parallel parking and my arms around my
girl like this
wow that's right [__] yeah that's cool
you're parallel parking you have your
arm around her like this yeah that is
cool man what does she do oh she
arm behind her i turn around and go
whoop one night or [__] nice nice
okay and then get out and go to whole
foods
yeah yeah it's not yeah that's pretty
cool to parallel park but backing in is
the way to go i think i think backing in
is the way to go always i always do it
also if you have a boss car back in
england that's pretty dope yeah true
because people get to see the front of
them last night at the improv the lot
there yeah right next to me back then
yep backed in here too oh you did yep
dude i was back in always
how about when uh was gonna say how
about when uh it says only head in
parking
get the [__] out of here and also
compact spaces they don't exist also
tesla spots at the airport come on dude
well i i guess i'll save you a car there
but like compact and then i'll put the
charger into my gas tank yeah it seems
dangerous oh yeah they're very
definitely i don't like to get i don't
like the uh the compact space only no no
dude do you know how many [__]
compact cars there are versus every car
is not a compact car every car is so big
dude and there's like f what do they
mean like the little smart cars like
you're more like a little honda
yeah but like there's so many compact
spaces [__] that dude oh no i parked no
matter what okay i'm hoping to argue
yeah i'm like let's see here dude i
can't argue with you
yeah yeah doing your bronco
hey
what's up men
got a king intersting it for you
dating a bottle girl
so it's basically my job
to flirt with men to get them to buy
alcohol
and get them drunk
um
i'm not too good at flirting but it's my
job so
would you be cool with your girl doing
that
gang gang buzz buzz if she looked like
you i'd be in i would do whatever
yeah she should be fighting in russia i
like it i get it though all right you
know yeah yeah yeah you're right bro
i get it i get she looks like a disney
character yeah she's hot but that's why
she's a [__] bottle girl
right but i i get it i get why it's uh i
get why it guys get jealous but like you
got to be secure if you're if you're not
the kind of guy that can't handle that
it's not for you yeah you can't be with
that kind of a girl well like could you
be with like let's say like your wife
let's say when you better level yeah and
she was a stripper yeah like badass
stripper but like she's making money
yeah like she's like oh here's the louis
vuitton off-whites air force ones i got
you seven g's oh yeah this is cool but
she's not going to the boom boom room
but she's rubbing that out
dudes and titties yeah i um her name's
cinnamon well i say you can't that's
definitely a black stripper cinnamon
or stripper in portland okay
oh speaking from experience sounds like
but yeah um no i think that
i think that
you have to
be
i you know
i think it's i would i think if i met
the girl and she was doing that then i
could understand it and i could but if
like if she now wanted to do it then i
would be like whoa what the [__] i can't
deal with this now like i've dated i
dated a girl that told me right away
that she's like
literally like paid like was paid for
sex and i was like okay i'm glad you
told me that up front well i'm rock hard
so i know so so i know that
um
and uh we dated for a few months and it
ended up i literally i've given you a
lot of money
i literally wouldn't care yeah i do not
care i mean if you have kids it's like
bottle service that's what you i don't
know way different of course right yeah
yeah yeah if you have kids
she's a stripper she's on only fans like
what if your girl was like hey babe like
like you met with the manager he says he
can make a hundred yeah okay a month
yeah
yeah would you let her do it
i mean if we needed to maybe no i'm
saying right now like you're good no
why would you do it no i'd be like why
babe what would it what what is there a
number you would let her do it
and she's not she's not you know sucking
dudes out yeah no i know she's playing
but i get it you know she's just like
showing her ass playing with the kitty i
just talking
rock hard dude well i'm already hard uh
i don't know man i mean there's always a
number for something right 500k a month
that's a lot of money that's what i'm
saying oh she has to be in lingerie
rubbing her kitty or what no we're
thinking
just your feet and ass oh no vag
i mean yeah okay you know i guess feet
is we but sure i guess 500 000 a month a
month but she's gonna have to keep the
subscriptions up so one time she has
like a a chocolate covered banana she's
just deep throating it and she's like
that might be where i draw the line i
don't know man now that i've seen that
these bottle girls make money though
dude i dated a bottle girl yeah yeah
yeah and she made all the money one of
the hardest working people i know the
problem is is the hours they aged them
like [__]
yeah like redheads like she aged so fast
and then her feet hurt all the time and
then they're basically nocturnal animals
yeah they don't see the sun no they
don't see the sun they turn into ursula
basically but she got so much cash she
bought like seven properties oh well
that's good because a lot of people just
buy like [__] shoes and necklaces and
[__] yeah because they're not good with
money but this is uh yeah save your
money save your money is she does she
have a dude i forget is she saying she
has a dude and then he's it bothers him
or she's just saying what do you think
about it she's been dating yeah it's all
insecure dude it is insecure
i don't care at all yeah i think i would
i think i would not carry i don't care
yeah yeah i don't care at all i think it
you got to find the right dude you got
to find the right dude that doesn't give
you there's a ton of them there are you
dude with confidence and also has his
own [__] right right he's obsessed with
you and playing video games at home all
the goddamn time it's gonna get dicey
but then but then mommy's making that
money
i'm not saying i do this but i feel like
a lot of bottle service girls probably
get cheated on because they're out
there they're working oh they get
cheated on yeah because they're working
during friday and series so the type of
guy that would date a very pretty bottle
girl oh such a good point nick isn't
worried about oh word up dude that's a
great point fist bump ear pump wow that
is a great point because the guy who
could get a hot chick as a bottle
service girl and then she's always
working and then he's out on the prowl
at other places seeing other bottle type
girls
and they would yeah
the plot thickens bro yeah she is a
tough gig because yeah the the douche
that like she's a 10. so the duchy's
gonna pull has his [__] together she's
always working thursday friday saturday
sunday she's working the pool parties
he's like cool story yeah i'm about my
boys yeah and my boys are [__] cool
too because we remember all us we came
to see you and that's how we met you and
we were in the [__] booth and you
came and brought the sparklies over dude
this yeah dude this chick is getting
cheated on yeah if she's being
if she's not single yeah and she needs
some counseling i'm here it's all
tough it's all tough life is hard
just keep going
and never [__] stop and get that
money and buy properties yeah life's a
garden dig it oh [__] i hate that me too
me dude i don't like that that's that's
that's that's why
that's a shirt that you'd get
like an in-law it's a bumper sticker
like mike life's a garden dig dig it
hate it
no no don't ever say that that might be
the title this guy's a [__] ten two
chris brendan hopefully savage's last
name is c savage
his first name i bet when someone just
just trusts [__] hey [__] savage here
freeze cut savage on the case or it's
cocky savage that'd be sick [__] savage
go see [__] savage over there yeah yeah
all right we gotta find we got you know
who we need for this who [__] savage
and his sister
freeze villains he doesn't even say he
says villains do it villains
like he's mr incredible yeah
all right so
he hey [__] savage look like he has a
problem turn off his body cam
[__] savage yeah you keep turning off
the camera and beating people up dude if
this guy i would be on his body cam i'd
be like is your name for a real savage
bro that would be me and his [__] all
fisheyed lens
arrested like this really your name's
[__] savage yeah i uh saw a guy in the
airport one time had a shirt that said
savage but he had a button down that was
unbuttoned over it and it just said vag
oh
that's great you ready to know that he's
great calling him from iowa he's an 18
year old copper i have a king understand
it for you guys um i know brennan will
have a good amount of input on this but
uh
nicotine pouches
[Music]
i do them pretty much
all day
every day
i wouldn't say i need to but it's kind
of just like a little pick me up it gets
me through the day a little bit more uh
easier
um but yeah king interesting and uh
brendan if you would uh you're a lot
bigger than everyone there
please force uh chris theo and eric to
try one i wish i could understand it um
i'd like them to king interesting after
they've had the real thing so nice yeah
king interesting nicotine pouches uh
gang gang buzz buzz sore
oh
dude yeah what do one no no no no no no
no way you want to know what you want to
do i want none i want i get apple in my
pocket what do you want no thank you
that's too many flavors to have on you
there's thing about being a cop when
you're running that nicotine
all you want
i'm gonna throw up no just do one
there's six milligrams not heavy i do
four at a time uh i go through three
cans a day but the thing is when you run
out of them you need a little edgy if
you're a cop a little edgy yeah things
start popping off turn the body cam off
take your aggression out because you'll
have nicotine yeah oh man
savage just shot a shoplifter like
that's like oh man he [__] he's like
i don't know my nicotine man yeah
and i'm with cocky savage yeah dude i
feel like um i feel like uh don't you
know don't do it all day though because
you'll have no lips you'll end up having
no lips right now
are you 70 well no because there's no
there's no in there it's coming back
it's okay in that one okay cool i mean
my gum like kind of has a weird thing
but it's not going in later on you're
just like
[__] savage
freeze cut savage
i knew uh chris when there would be a
lot to say about it but i wanted to see
if you take one
eric wouldn't understand he would eat it
and be like now what eric won't yeah i
mean they're going to try diet coke you
just keep it in your lip though and you
just suck on it all day yeah
and then when i'm on the road sometimes
daddy a vape
and that's uh they outlawed it
it's done
no more jewels do you think that's gonna
stop it's not no but that's crazy bro
that's a huge hit
i thought they outlawed it in like
airports no no they're saying that fda
crack down on it and they can't [__]
sell jewels anymore well i get it
because it's like enticing for kids yeah
yeah it's like purple and neon and [__]
one's fruit loop flavor yeah they do
oh is it really
my future
i call him vape daddy he has nine vapes
on him at all times whatever flavor you
want he has them in his pocket if he
orders jewel labs to remove products
from us marketing that's crazy that's a
huge hit that's a huge hit let's go
underground they're done
bro
did you ever see that kid who was on bar
from barstool who
he was on uh cnn talking about vape and
they thought he was just like a
enthusiastic vape fan
and
he was just clowning him
oh really yeah this kid was great vape
guy
look i'm 22 years old so i'm going to
watch them legally and honestly they're
just cool like they're cool you rip them
there's nothing cooler than blowing a
fat cloud like that they call me the
colossus of cloud i just it helps my
swag it helps my drip i just love
walking around it's really good for
getting chicks too and kids it can cause
concentration problems memory problems
problems with decision making you are
inhaling propylene glycol formaldehyde
traces of metals and chemicals you to
have trouble breathing beyond oxygen
put some people in the in the emergency
room um poor tommy over there is gasping
for air and coughing
but 10 20 years from now he's going to
have trouble breathing he may develop
chronic bronchitis and and you smoked
cigarettes before and was this your way
to get off or no no no no cigarettes
cigarettes are bad for i would never do
anything that's bad for your lungs or
anything i just stick to juul or it's
also known
didn't know no no she's [__] idiots
that's hilarious
wow vape king
amazing that's hilarious
i like the smell of the vape oh remember
no i hate it one smell is nice and then
again i'm like crying it's too bro in a
small room we're always in a green room
maybe the next day right you have to
fade i hate [__] vaping dude bro i
hate i'd rather you smoke cigarettes for
real oh wow 100 uh i don't even mind
that i mean you do nothing dude no
nicotine no vaping nothing nope just
coffee yeah god does nothing for me
though start living dude dude i told you
this before life's a garden
dig i know a life's a garden dig it but
also kristen made me do the [__] uh
ivy drip or whatever the [__] yeah yeah
she's like it's amazing how it makes you
feel where i try four times literally
zero different afterwards oh wow yeah
did you do it oh yeah and it feels good
i'm all the time and it feels good oh
yeah the best bro she's just gonna come
off the road yeah it doesn't
at i did it four times i'm like you got
all the vitamins add another bag add
more vitamins bro i never felt anything
and i'm not lying like i just
legitimately never and then she was like
i saw the bill once and i was like i'm
not doing this anymore it's like six
hundred dollars doing this [__] yeah
i feel great do it but especially if
you're sick it's just great hung over
hung over sick or yeah you're gonna get
rid of your illness i just don't feel
different
at all and i try i want to
i would love to have a thing that makes
me feel good
oh well
vitamins wise
not [__] drugs crack all right well
what's up king of sing fam it's your boy
johnny here i got a king you're singing
tattooing yourself oh cool
probably not the best hobby but it is
what it is thanks for everything you
guys do gang
are not
good yeah yeah yeah good if you're good
at it do it
nightmare those are [__] is that a
boxing kangaroo
it kind of looks like his ass is on the
front yeah it does yeah
on second look that's a great tattoo but
like it's on his legs so he [__]
gives a [__] you know it's one of those
like optical illusions yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm rock hard
hairy ass here we go his hair got hair
on it yeah it's it's you know if you
like it dude [__] it are you getting
more tapped i want to yeah we're i'm
going to london you know and i told i i
i was great hit me up i said if you want
to [__] tattoo me i just told him on
my podcast congratulations i just came
out yesterday congratulations it doesn't
matter brought to you by super super
cult but so we um
we uh i said hey hit me up artists in
london i would love to get a tattoo in
london nobody hit you up not well no i
didn't it came out today so where do you
know where you're gonna get it uh up
front uh in london but are you going no
i'm kidding oh i want to
i want to do the front i do but i'm i
feel like i need to get tattoos on the
rest of my body first i want to that
stresses me out to get this front yeah
god where are you going to get there you
know what i'm getting a bow tie [__]
[Laughter]
[__] savage like this with his lip like
this [__] savage
um
freeze no i don't know
um you don't know where you get on the
front
it's a ball no i'm not gonna do i'm not
gonna do it in london but i i do want to
get it eventually i want to get all
tatted up yeah you want to get made by
my chest or like you know my arm i still
got my arms you know you get a lot of
space yeah i got space free
property there yeah would you get a king
in the sting in the wing tattoo during a
recording in here well i would if you
had more people i would a an actual
tattoo tattoo about this podcast or
anything but
i mean
like what if he did wings the wing yeah
but not well i already have some wings
as the thing
this the eagles that's a full bird i
have a plane i have a [__] paper
airplane i'm a little bit like it's bird
city honestly i'm sponsored by southwest
i know i know
i would get a tattoo live yeah um i
would do it live yeah deal wouldn't it
sure no no way well they don't have any
tattoos right no they're scared of you
here's the gun right yeah no we could
all get tattoos that would be cool no i
don't have any i mean i didn't know chin
was that tied up i just barely got it
though but this guy got it the guy that
does it johnny from uh mojave creative
he would come in to do it because he's
fans of the show oh nice and he does
great work cool i mean
during the show would be a terrible
thing
maybe maybe on what do you call it on uh
visually it might be okay though you
know what i mean yeah if you're watching
the business it's a different story
the show's gonna be over it'd be one
person ah that's it i guess it was small
if it's small enough we could all do it
right just a quick clip a quick clip of
it on the show yeah but if we if you
just got a small logo like say i got a b
he got a wing right here
he could do that
we all get him right here yeah
like charles manson um
i think it's good we should cool
deal let's take a little break from
chatting about [__] with each other
because ufc 276 is here man i'm doing
fine the calf slicer baby that's one of
the moves they use in ufc you know about
that yeah dude how about that hard scarf
daddy that peruvian necktie what about
that rattle wrangler dude where they
freaking what about that freaking baby
beater i don't know that one but listen
ufc 276 is here this saturday you can
watch it you can watch actually the
fight companion 7 p.m pacific live on
thick boy beautiful crew daddy
um but watch it with us and you can make
some bank with our friends at draftkings
sportsbook the official sports brand
partner the ufc new customers can bet
five dollars on any fire to win and get
100 and free bets win or lose
whether it's izzy via knockout or
canonnaire gets it done probably be a
decision all right and draftkings same
game
you can turn another small bet into a
big payday so if you bet in small you
can win big they say it yep ufc 276 you
can play the same game parlay if it hits
you win double go to the shop picks i
picked izzy
barbarino over robbie lawler and
sean o'malley to get it done you will
boost your odds you just click on the
brennan shop picks and that's how you
get the parley rolling download the
draftking sportsbook app now use prom
code k-a-t-s at five dollars on any ufc
276 fighter to win and get 100 in free
bets no matter what that
that's code k-a-t-s this saturday at
draftking sports book the
official sports betting partner of ufc
minimum agent eligibility restriction
supply he's showing us for details nick
davis is not allowed to
bet this guy's got one
brendan theo chris eric good to see you
hey it's sam from up in washington
brandon just saw you in portland uh this
last weekend had a great time wearing
dick boy sweatshirts
so i got a king understanding it for you
um
spirit weeks at work
my work occasionally does spirit weeks
and today it looks like you love western
day wow that's why i got the
big foam cowboy hat because it is the
only piece of western attire that i own
we're in portland
anyway
yeah spirit weeks uh kinder stinger gang
gang buzz buzz soar
and
nice
that guy is a [__] cartoon character
in the 90s on mtv um he's peter griffin
he's a little thin for that but yeah um
i would say
spirit weeks are something that people
who have companies that they don't
understand that like
like what really actually personality is
i hate that [__] like i hate it just
like just be the people that work at the
job a job is not supposed to be fun
don't be trying to have fun at the job
you're gonna cr create morale and like
yeah but create morale by creating a
wine shirt friday no no no
the last thing you're gonna think boy
monday through friday's casual [__] yeah
yeah
these guys got [__] flip-flops i know
shorts fire them dude i think
yeah you're right
i think that um i don't wear suits the
last thing i want is anybody to [__]
see any of my outfits that i'm wearing
whether it's morale or not
morale building or not is to be like
this oh
dude
that is
like that's why i don't really like
halloween you know you just maybe if
you're going to dress up as like batman
okay but it's like people are like you
know oh they put a [__]
like it's like they dress blue and
they're holding a chicken with a cord
like look i'm chicken cord on blue and
people are like oh like dude don't ever
that's the worst dude yeah i don't i
don't dig it either because my son's in
summer camp right now and they have
theme days and you know they're set
they're that's fine if they're sick it's
no it's not why because between four and
seven i think my son's six and like last
week was star wars day yeah they don't
[__] dude uh right i don't give a [__]
about right right right right
so he's you know yeah and yoda had to
paint his face green or something oh
right right he's like who am i like
you're yoda yeah kids will love it also
i want my kid to have a personality
organically don't make him dress up like
[__] boba fett huh agree yeah yeah
yeah
who's this weird toilet theo brendan
what's up she's at uab my name is jordan
and i'm coming to you from the great
state of sweden home alabama
with a king understand
big [__]
i'm talking about fat [__] liz i'm
talking about us free
that's my king you're saying
big women tall women
mr vaughn what's a girl got to do to get
you to climb her like a tree
who should you say yeah i've heard
people call me people i don't have
people so you have people call
me gang gang buzz buzz love you guys
thanks
uh and she is a person that's the thing
though when you're a big girl you got
personality for days yeah and now she's
all scared she's funny yeah right fun
did you whoa dude holy [__] that's nice
incredible she did that wow that is cool
wow
um that's incredible
wait uh sports illustrated is going
we'll take girl on the left yeah that's
hilarious yeah
did did you know where she was just by
seeing the wall behind
[Laughter]
how tall is your girl
five seven
what about yours
uh
five five yeah maybe five six i
i mean
big like tall i love tall i mean
that on the left is a little is a little
big but like
what
uh do you work for pixar no she's gonna
hey
i'll say [__]
the girl is not happening but she has a
beautiful face is what i'm saying not on
the left
on the right she does that
yeah yeah yeah i'm looking at the right
it'd be cool but i'm saying like hey but
be cool no but i'm saying like she
that's a little big on the left
was about to say
was about to say he even thought so
you're you're saying i i should say it's
all people are all equally beautiful
that's not true no don't say that oh
you're saying that you know oh she's
saying you know you know on the left
what's happening you're saying she's
very fast yeah it's not happening
yeah but yeah you said she's a little
big on the left yeah yeah i mean so
you're saying i should say a lot big
yeah yeah i i'd appreciate it she's a
beautiful face though on the right now
nothing like the face is in there you
can't see her face it's in there it's
also bad lighting she brought it out she
brought it on the right her face now i
just i don't i'm just saying if she was
to kiss another girl in a pixar movie
i think that that's beautiful man
uh big girl i mean listen
the girl on the left not my style but if
you know if that's your thing
god bless you more power to you yeah
there's a big girl and like like big
girls are hot some big girls are hot you
know what i mean yeah but that was hot
that's i i don't really know about
health and like this whole thing that
narrative
yeah i don't but like that's unhealthy
right on the left yeah through the room
right so that's why i don't celebrate
liz or whatever but i know what people
are like people like to pretend with the
narrative like oh it's all healthy it's
not healthy right yeah yeah yeah so um
yeah it looks like to me not only that
is somebody that's that big
you know a little big right yeah
i think like oh then it might be bad for
living wise and i can't be a a part of
that because i don't want to be eating
like that and if i'm going to have kids
with this woman i don't want to i don't
want them to die early right there you
go now a tall woman i love i i dated a
six one girl
no [__] it dude put on he'll be taller
than me i'll look up and be like where
are we going oh wow yep drive wow you
drive i don't give a [__] i'm 62 though
but like if i was five eight might be a
little different but like
yeah six one dude love it bro i mean i
listen love it if rihanna was six i'm
the man i'd put up with it i'm the man
when someone's six one
i mean if like meg the stalin was six
too i'd be fine with it fine fine i
don't i don't really care but but meg
the stallion is a big girl right
i'm not that tall
but she's that's all
big right she's she's thick yeah stick
with three so that's a big girl
uh girl oh
oh wow that's bad wow yeah she's hot as
[__] yeah yeah i'm in yeah she'll have
this i'm in yeah fine fine i really
don't care i think she married [__]
she's a savage savage oh yeah yeah yeah
she married [__] cocky yeah she's bad
as [__] now brittany grinder not my
style that's um she could be 411. it's
not working for me that's right yeah but
that's not because yeah okay and then
russia said we're gonna let we're gonna
keep you here for a little bit what do
you mean oh really oh yeah she tried
getting to russia and she had uh
marijuana in her vape oh and she was
cleared because she was playing over
there and she had the her one of her
friends over there was an olive guard
well they go to russia and the old
guards have to flee the [__] country
oh so the holograms like [__] i have
qriket wireless i can't contact you
right now right and then she's stuck in
the prison up
the prison yeah she's in russian prison
prison oh they got to get her back
you know who we need [__] savage
we need [__] savage but this shows you
that
if that was steph curry he'd be back the
next day this shows you what we think of
the wnba
wedding goes yeah we'll get around to it
yeah yeah if it was zion williams yeah
we got him back in hours yeah well also
zion williams would [__] get out of
russia you would [__]
you know i mean
just dunking on [__] with a
basketball what the [__] is going on
um that is insane wow yeah he'd be back
steph curry would be back on a first
class flight oh no he'd be flying
private he'd be on air force one 30
minutes later no
steph curry would literally be flying
just yes biden would be like we'll give
you superpowers just show you wnba like
yeah figure it out i didn't even know
she was over there honestly oh yeah so
that's the thing we all forgot she's
still in there
yeah like eating porridge that's a tough
gig wow but fine it's fine i don't i
don't care on height i don't
know
i mean what about the other way
what about the other way like if
someone's three five
oh like dating a small person yeah or
just i don't know you know i don't know
if they're technically a small person
but three five but all but they look
great they don't have like a bigger head
or whatever the [__] yeah come on but
the thing is with small people they have
bigger heads right like right if they
put a regular regular body and then they
all it's impossible this is science yeah
look it up okay every short person has a
fat ass it's just it's condensed so you
feel that blood so it's a thick kind of
even though your small person you're a
thick girl yeah hey what's up brendan
let's go yeah i'll drive
i don't like that wow i'm out
i think that's racist bro well i think
310 and seven foot is where i draw the
line
what's the show i dated a five foot my
girlfriend was five foot once
i've seen it was five foot baddies yeah
yeah yeah never went and then never 411
is
you know hey
but if she was 310 that only fans is
popping
oh yeah because there's like a weird
fetish
how tall somebody is on the [__]
internet unless they stand next to
somebody yeah but if they know you're
small and then her little hands they
would be like wow your [__] pillow's
big
what's the deal dude the other girl only
friends with all the extra big [__] in
her room
and then you see her out in public and
you're like oh my god hello what's up
it's me from other times
what up
this is dion coming at you live from san
diego nice i got a debate club for you
guys i'll be there in july homeboy
showering in the morning or showering at
night in the morning a lot of people
that just shower in the morning
even after a long day sure nice
right
um so yeah let me know what you think
chris
keep stacking those racks all the way up
to the sky yes tickle scott's feet there
we go
gang
buzz buzz
sword
that's right eric i can sing too
um see me at a singing contest and then
see me in a foot race oh
wow that's insecure right i was gonna
say jay-z
um all right so listen talented
gentlemen uh
yeah so he said um what did he say yeah
what did he say what did he say a shower
in the morning all right all right
morning good morning that's how you're
going tomorrow you got to start your day
like that yeah it's weird to have sleep
on you throughout the day my you know
chicks do it like my girl does it she'll
like wake up sometimes she'll shower at
night yeah before she goes out so
strange yeah they like being in their
pjs and [__] you know not me bro i
shower in the morning oh you're well
your morning is still night for me
though because it's five o'clock in the
morning so you wake up daddy wakes about
noon yeah um i think that showering in
the morning is the way to go i mean
clearly yeah
start your day dude
yeah start your day like that but also
cold showers the nice way to go yeah
yeah oh oh no
why would you do that because feels good
wakes you up
i don't want you to say that anymore
[Laughter]
dude i'm gonna tell you again life's a
garden i know dig it daddy but here's
the thing it's so interesting that you
said that you were going to be in san
diego coming up because i'm going to be
in denver coming up at the bellco and
you can go to crusade.com and i'm going
to be in albany actually and i'm going
to also be in [__] boston
massachusetts and washington dc yep with
two shows at the wang and then boston d
and then washington dc and then atlanta
and savannah georgia and peoria that's
too many days though yeah and raleigh so
it's crazy though that you said that
because i'm also going to be in
different places go to chrisley.com not
only did i be in san diego in july but
i'm also uh july 14th or 16th fort wayne
indiana oh wow that's great fort wayne
indiana never been there then the next
week your boy was it the [__] 19th
through the 21st is in san diego laugh
actor downtown and then it goes
baltimore then we're in boston
and then appleton wisconsin i'm all over
daddy i like you though well what about
the fact that i'm going to be in dallas
coming up would you go to chrisley.com
for that yeah you would but you wouldn't
you said downtown not downtown and it
kind of like it's like downtown
speaking
go ahead
speak of your indiana show what's up
cats hyphen w
first off no dance nice uh i got a
debate club for you uh i live in fort
wayne indiana oh nice friend and i hear
that i'm in your fort wayne show oh cool
appreciate you coming out you get chris
and theo and brian to come out one day
but brian comes i have to get a smaller
venue he ain't selling nothing no no no
but anyway guys a big club uh me and my
girl want to be the generation that you
know moves out of indiana
but we don't know if we should do it
when we're young or we should do when
the parents pass on
uh we don't know one question uh we're
not thinking about any kids and if we do
have one is it better to have the kid in
indiana he's all king you're seeing it
killing your parents
or would you just like
that
let me know what you guys think
gang gang buzz buzz and
so nice i like the guy
i think that you got to just [__] go
bro you got to go don't wait till you're
older you're never going to go sore bro
sore dude i'm going to tell you
something that my dad told me life's a
garden dig it no you gotta relocate get
out of fort wayne indiana come on over
to the sunny side now your taxes here
and be a little high
california might not be you might not
have to go to california but you can go
to [__] other places that are not
fort wayne indiana no offense
you know but uh
the bottom line is he wants to leave
right so
don't wait for yourself don't wait to
have it the second you have kids is
gonna be harder way harder yeah dude i'm
i'm [__] so go now dude yeah go now
go actually go today as you're listening
to this stop it right now pack all your
[__] up and don't tell yourself honestly
and drive don't even pack tell no one
don't tell your wife leave yes yeah
ditch the girl go to brendan's house yes
well you said yes yep do we want to do a
quick indiana related name game since
the judge
what do you mean you guys just go back
and forth naming things related to
indiana bro i know zero thinks hoosiers
that's it how would you want to judge
that zero thank you
hoosiers okay uh johnny appleseed in uh
indy nascar 500
um hoosiers larry bird indiana pacers
[__] yeah
kkk would say oh murder
murder a lot of murder that's gary
indiana but yeah still still
wait is pacers there yeah indiana
dude fort fort wayne fort wayne
larry bird
uh a guy with a doesn't make a dent
shirt
with a [__] cuban link chain who
wants you
i think there's a tie dude johnny
appleseed yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you did say uh indy 500 which is a
[__] i missed that which is idiotic
so you win you died in fort wayne this
guy johnny apples oh
no johnny epstein how sad she's never
going to leave johnny fc died there you
go jacob are stinging it getting buried
in fort wayne indiana
um all right we got a couple more okay
cool sounds good
rick glassman what's up king sting in
the wing and the sing hook my boy eric
up with the with some [__] bro wow but
anyways you guys love the debate club
big boy bike club and also i'm a patreon
subscriber so
this could be on either one please nice
hold up chin and nick too
anyways
road cycling does that count as leg day
for the pros yes oh no we still gotta
hit heavy squats and [__] no
let me know what y'all think
gang gang buzz buzz
sword
or some [__] like that mommy just got to
run over
oh my god i mean how fit do you want to
be bro cycling is great that's that's
what that's what yeah daddy does here
but here's the thing about road cycling
i used to
go down to pangos in your mouth but yeah
yep i just threw up in my mouth because
too much nicotine and caffeine and
alcohol yeah and i'm off three hours of
sleep but the thing is is i used to take
my road bike down to payne canyon and
there's no road so you're sharing the
road with the cars and i'd see this guy
going up and down all the time and i
didn't see him like that's weird and i
get to the bottom there's usually a crew
hanging at the bottom like about to go
back up and i go uh usually rodney's got
ryan when you take oh he didn't hear you
another like he got hit last week man
died oh [__] bro they they go he's the
fourth one this year and i went
oh really and i've never done it again
oh so it's very rare i go on the road
now now usually i do convert the tires
so i can go on the the dirt now because
and then you know you remember sean
bradley the basketball player played for
the dallas you definitely don't know but
yeah he got hit on his bike he's
paralyzed now
recently
cycling yeah yeah people die all the
time it's so dangerous
so i stopped doing it i had kids i can't
[__] paralyze you know yeah oh man
that's sad yeah no cycling is very
dangerous yeah
i didn't know that i mean i guess
because i wouldn't people are taxing and
[__] and no one shares the road with
bikes you know yeah yeah i'll tell you
one thing though people texting you
listen fellas if you're on the road out
there and you wear all those tights and
you got like sponsors on your back
dude and you're with your boys and you
get together every sunday morning to
escape the family unless you're
sponsored by the u.s postal service like
lance armstrong don't dress like that
right i dressed like a hypebeast yeah i
got baggy shorts on it you bag your
shirt on i look pretty fly in that box
yeah yeah yeah i don't wear the tights
no i do i keep it real like oh really
yeah that's good yeah yeah yeah and they
know yeah you get off your bike you go
in a coffee shop no one has any idea
that you were on a bike except my shoes
clink like my [__] horse right but
you got to wear those to do that well i
take them off and i'm barefoot wow yeah
oh wow okay well i didn't realize you
were so [__] awesome well
you are though yeah thank you someone
said to the cats in the wild they saw
eric on his honeymoon
that is
there is nothing
cooler than music
that is i thought you were cool bro that
is that's
[__] yeah it gave me that dad's [__]
[__] shoes how many times did it
bounce up and hit his [__] tooth too
but i love that he picked the music
like clearly he picked the music that
song is so dope dude
is that the streets of rage soundtrack
that is so [__] ill boom
all these people that's that's
that's the song that [__] savage [__]
do yes
no that's the song cocktail which gives
his dick sucked by the other guys oh
nice dude gay cop yeah
um that is the illest video i've ever
seen in my life and then someone has a
uh
cats in the wild what theo's been doing
in his time up larping oh that's theo
that's the they're all theo right and
one of them is definitely theo but they
could all be well this is theo's family
this way some problems
[Music]
earth warrior
left oh my god there he is hey sometimes
i hate white people
yeah what's up with earth warrior though
you could just say warrior
but just warriors earth war here know
that we're on planet earth i know but
that's why it's redundant we're all on
earth look at that guy wow that face is
so that makes me mad dude i wish he was
an apocalypto he's just the white
warrior yeah
he's what the [__] is uh oh that's that
account can't see this or what it is
can't wait is that real nick is that
like uh that's right parody is that guys
awesome cat catatonic youths that like
that sounds so funny dude do you know
how big of a freak that girl is with the
face tattoos
i mean you can see it right there yeah
she's an earth warrior though so
earthworms wow that is unreal this
account is hilarious they play some
really gangster [__] um
that's earth warrior i love how spaced
out they were too that's hilarious guys
just get together they even they don't
like each other or it was during covered
when they filmed that so they're
socially distant earthquakes
earth warrior
um
yeah one more earth warrior
or maybe two if we need it oh is that a
snakey
tapeworm
a lizard
what is that oh it's a it's a leaf oh
it's a leaf what up cat's family i was
uh first of all just bury your body just
acknowledge that i am the creepy one
because i'm on my roof looking at my
neighbor's house but hell yeah i'm just
up here cleaning my gutters and noticed
something
that code for masturbating real great uh
my neighbors have a
backyard pride flag
they support but they don't want anyone
to know it's hilarious
i'm proud or aren't you
[Laughter]
you're proud or what
dude let me know king interesting that
literally flag was because he obviously
is against gays and that flag's just for
him because they know he cleans out his
gutters
they're like we want you to know
[__]
yeah he's trying not to get canceled
yeah how about this [__] this is cool
right that's hilarious a backyard flag
is so they're probably the the people
that live there are gay yeah yeah yeah i
mean well no i don't know maybe not
probably though right i guess if it's in
a backyard yeah yeah or they had like a
party for pride week
oh yeah
and they had their gay friends over like
buy flags bro that's hilarious put it in
the front
put the flag in the front i mean the
husband was like let's not get it yeah
yeah well we can put it in a you we can
put it underground it's it's more for
them though you know yeah yeah
uh
they put it in the back
um
so yeah dude that's cr that is uh
really funny and good good observation
sir and uh good luck with the gutters my
man you're a peeping tom so
okay let's see how this is deal
he's happy nick had to do a quick uh
thing for you so
that's my subaru [__] yeah what that for
a thousand dollars nice great deals i'm
in dodge i've had that for a couple
years that was two thousand dollars so
quick hanging out bro
driving beaters
three grand two cars
makes it through what do you guys think
let me know thanks bro dude in the
current climate you could flip those
guys make money this guy's rich bro
this guy's invested in [__] cars that
have that you can transport [__] in yeah
but also that truck that he bought what
do you say a thousand dollars
it must have
500 million miles on it yeah because
that's not a bad truck no it's a little
beat up but two thousand dollars yeah
yeah yeah this guy's obviously a worker
bro that's guys you got two cars life's
good we're balling dude this guy's
balling
and three grand total
forget it one breaks down you got the
other one
you know what i'm saying no
subaru outback's kind of ill i like that
oh really yeah yeah you hate them yeah
unless you're a a trans ant i don't
really dig if you get the [__] uh
knobby wheels like the bigger thick
wheels it looks [__] kind of dope i
think really yeah kind of than that well
and they're not for me but i think that
they're nice to look at when they see
the new buzz lightyears
in your shoes
i don't know man
i i want it to take calvin maybe i maybe
i will maybe like when that happens i
don't i don't think it's wrong but maybe
just to slight disney i'll be like hey
popcorn when that happens i don't want
dizzy get my money yeah i don't like
them anymore um because of what just in
general just in general yeah i don't
like it you think that [__] walt
disney's a nazi yeah yeah yeah i don't
like what what they're doing with the
parks overcrowded now it's a beast dude
i don't like that they didn't have tim
allen as buzz so i looked into that so
that's because he's young right well
that that's that's because they want a
younger one but here's the thing tim
allen didn't get canceled and because of
his political beliefs because uh tim
allen has a uh series for santa claus
series on disney plus so he's still on
disney
oh they were saying because he's well
republican or something yeah trump yeah
yeah
is he outspoken
oh really he's tim the tool man no i
don't forget i mean i i know i don't
give a [__] if he likes trump or not but
i'm just saying i know the public and
the [__] media would be like no and
so but he didn't get canceled because
he's on disney yeah all right disney
didn't cancel they were pissed at chris
evans the voice but
who who was pissed
every fans got it okay name somebody
chris evans is the new [__] captain
tim allen well he's not though but he is
though when it comes to oh dude
whiteness
when it comes to chris little america no
not at all who how
chris pratt
oh i i meant chris evans is more like a
soy i meant chris pratt who's the new
voice of lightyear chris evans oh i
thought it was captain america no chris
pratt's great
chris evans yeah oh i meant chris
different animal right i i thought we
were talking about chris pratt i totally
agree chris evans is a woke boy right
yes yeah yeah right all right totally be
cool i messed up yeah
strike it from the record
stricken
we should do one more okay cool that's
brendan
what's up brendan what's up theo what's
up eric what's up chris
well
maybe some kind of [__] variation of
the four y'all nice
i got a king a stinger a winger
beautiful for you jumping into your
neighbor's sumbitching pool hell yeah
while they at work amazing
it's not a big deal they're probably
going to see this but i'm just wondering
you [__] around in somebody else's
hot bath
oh dude i don't want to get shot
no i don't want to get shot bro and
drinking bro what if he's going to die
in there dude i
would n oh that would make me nervous as
[__] yeah i'd be listening to the job
yeah
if anyone didn't have a job it's that
guy right there in that image dude
that's that's a sugar mama i'm sure that
the neighbors don't give a [__] but
still don't abuse the privilege right if
you abuse the privilege don't abuse it
because here's the thing let them deal
with all the maintenance all that [__]
you're just gonna jump on in there with
the big ass and he looks like he's going
to cannonball right in that thing i mean
this guy is literally randy quaid in
[__] the vacation movie yeah you know
what i mean like not even using his
[__] pool that's amazing bro i love
this guy yes i'd probably love him for
like five minutes and then be like wow
this guy's annoying well if it's your
pool and you come home he's always in
there yeah that's the thing
what are you doing yeah my rule would be
hey bro just don't be in the pool when i
get back oh i would say you can only go
in these hours uh-huh yeah yeah if
daddy's even close i don't want you
right right right right right and don't
post [__] stories on it no and don't
don't submit a video to a popular book
yeah exactly in our pool bro how you
using our pool yeah i don't want those
[__] at cats plus knowing about this
yes yep
it looks like he actually ended up
getting in a fight no side later no this
isn't oh
[__] oh wow what's this it looks exactly
like watching and they have fireball
poolside at least these guys are in
shape
oh the slowest oh and they're wet yeah
they can't do that they're wet start on
the ground oh [__] oh oh the the old man
can't fight
they're both hammered
you better stop you came after me
[Applause]
[Music]
wow i hate fights bro it's a dad
[__] oh dude i can't you know i watch
world star really everywhere i wake up
the world star
every morning first day i go to that's
horrible oh the [__] on there's insane i
can't watch that [__] i can't watch that
i like the one that says uh guy gets
caught slipping by the ops and you know
somebody getting shot or dying i can't
watch that dude this other guy just saw
in the corner of new york gets out the
dude's on the phone get just nonchalant
some fat black dude gets out shotgun you
hear him talking to him hits him in the
face above the gun and boom right in the
face
and this is just something you watch
it's 6 30 a.m daddy bro
what the [__] your kids are bye kids
world star dude yeah okay why did he do
the [__] hit first if he's gonna
disrespect disrespect before killing uh
that happened today yeah send it to me
i gotta like side watch it
i have to see it through i was gonna ask
you don't like it but when you scroll
past do you watch or do you well if i
don't know what's gonna happen i might
but if i knew that that was going to
happen i would not watch it yeah no no
no
but i don't follow those accounts
there there's even if we can get real
dark there's the worst one there this
guy in india proposed to his girl and
she told him no
he went cool story and then she was
walking back to her apartment he pulled
up on his motorcycle third world country
and then um
took a knife and then yeah she's not
with us anymore yeah it's dark
when was this
yesterday sent it to me
i liked faces of death when i was a kid
me too well i didn't really like it dude
oh i i
saw it it was very scary and you know
it's fake though a lot of it is it i
don't know i don't know that's what i
heard
it sounds like me you're talking about
and you don't know the world stars i
mean as legit as it gets
don't ever [__] say that
it's legitimate against oh man that
makes me sad that people
kill each other and [__]
yeah
on that it's kind of like it's kind of
like the news you watch but unfiltered i
know you know like seven people are shot
and they just have some stupid report
recapping what you just heard i'd rather
know that i like to see the real no dude
bro
i think this would be a lighter note to
go out on okay another seal same wow
same nose wow
what up boys uh coolest guy in iowa back
at it the old longboarder uh oh that's
right appreciate making it on hey i'm
gonna make this one quicker than the
last one
oh also shout out to eric griffin dude
since i submitted that video i became a
huge [__] eric griffin fan
definitely not making it short like you
said it [__] let's hear your king
as of
right now in life what is the thing that
you king what is the thing that you
sting
what is the thing that you wing you know
you're kind of getting into and uh
what's your saying dude what's your
favorite song right now
cool
that's a good one yeah so the one the
one thing in life you king my son
nice
and sting
world star dude getting [__] shot in
the face that's my sting well but you
want me to send it to you so it's also a
king you know no it's a sting i need to
make sure it's a sting okay send it to
me
and uh wing what's the wing jesus christ
uh you're into super cult that's new
super cult my new [__] yeah
it's my uh youtube my channel i changed
it over because i got the [__]
lifeline show on it too it's not just
crystalline youtube oh it's super cold
okay so because i got lifeline and
congratulations so go on awards for
super cool yeah yeah so go over and
[__] subscribe to that yeah you know
what i mean um on my youtube page super
cult that's a good one wing it and sing
bro i don't like music
no music
no
dude um i do like that one [__] david
gray song though that goes
on
it's such an old song see so sing that
one
in my head yeah or i like that fuel song
that goes
i haven't heard it heard it's [__]
[__] boy [__] though uh it's very housy
but it's not it's not his best the song
with 21 savage is great on there that's
about 21 savage is not good i agree yeah
he's very
very bad he's not yeah yeah that's
coming from guys and everyone knows it
deep down yeah he knows it uh king well
he said your son i mean i'd say my kids
yeah you do yeah you got it you're a dad
what the [__] drake
uh no drake drake is king oh yeah
drake's good drake's great
[__] i gotta listen to it on the way
home
yeah uh there's no fuel though
leave me on my heart
and then wing oh i like i'm although i'd
uh uh oh no no you haven't said anything
yet
wing would be uh bucket hats i'm getting
a bucket
that's my sting that's my sting bro if
you [__] show up in a bucket hat i'm
never doing another brand of shop and
friend show ever again next week i'm
showing minutes
off no i i won the raffle i guess
yes
i won the raffle is the worst thing to
say after that
dude
king world star listen my morning dude i
wake up i'm on world star watch people
get shot in the face i get an alert new
supreme drop rush over to the store i'm
watching worldstar i'm listening to rap
in the back right i go to supreme i win
a bucket hat
life is great king it
all your whole life is a king bro oh and
then for the sing it i'm going to play
uh a sample of brown song
i got brown's new song on here we'll get
flagged or no uh no no
we own him
all right gotcha
[Music]
arizona
makes me want to cry i can't listen to
music
[Music]
i don't know i like to feel how i'm
feeling already and i feel like when i
listen to that all the walls come down
and i just want to [__] cry [__]
cry dude oh man
this is a good time
i got so many problems
okay i'm like this seven copy of the day
yeah
i drink seven coffees a day too but i'm
like this
i'm telling you
i drink my seventh coffee
and i'll drink it like that in dallas
coming up in grand prairie dude he's
back the music goes off and he's firing
dude
go see emo chris
oh my dream emo comedy dude uh go see
chris dallas uh great grand saint
prairie whatever the [__] it's called
you said nothing but we have a library
dallas area
texas yeah yeah yeah in texas wichita
kansas that's where the btk killer is
from atlanta georgia lots of crime there
washington dc political crime stockton
california oakland california you know
where the [__] that is dude it's the
[__] murder tour baby september
peoria illinois rockford illinois that's
near chicago you know it's bad
on the police raleigh north carolina
that's where the [__] guy pushed that
woman down the stairs that's where the
staircase is and then we go to savannah
georgia it's actually very nice
also a lot of first 48's are filmed
there there we go keep it at murder
store but then denver colorado november
5th i'm from there yeah and it's nice
right it's all right it's nice yeah it's
nice it's got nice you know cheyenne
wyoming
uh no never been there no doing that
november in uh november 6. boston
november 12th albany november 13th
that's a new one lakeland florida lots
of incestual crime and uh jacksonville
florida lots of incestual crime so
december 2nd and december 3rd
chrisley.com tickets
ah god that's a lot of dates i will be
in fort wayne indiana i think it's july
14th or 16th
the week after i am in uh san diego at
the laugh factory downtown heart of san
diego lab factory san diego and then i
am in baltimore first week of uh a lot
of crime there's just a lot of crimes
i'm in baltimore and the fourth and
sixth boston at the uh end of september
irish crimes irish crimes appleton too
oh
no no september no crime there there you
go kids tickets at thickboy.com
hell yeah dude is that it
thanks guys yeah for winning yes see you
soon love you guys
thanks [__]
[Music]
how many times i gotta make this song
uh
[Music]
it's the king and the sting and the wing